the future is here but rather than the
dystopian rage-fueled battles of most
futuristic videogames steel circus
offers competition of another kind these
arenas play host to the solar system's
largest sporting event intrigued while
that here is everything you need to know
about steel circus
steel circus which is free-to-play on
steam is a multiplayer futuristic hero
sports game featuring fast paced PvP
matches two teams of three human control
players enter the arena and compete to
score goals in a game that combines
sports and hero genres think speedball -
meets rocket League with a dash of
overwatch and you're not far off from
what developers ironmountain interactive
are aiming for
[Music]
steel circus is not your standard sports
game huh I got the ball here we go
oh I exploded but before you jump kilt
first into the different characters and
abilities steel circus demands mastery
of the fundamentals getting to grips
with tackling passing dodging and
especially scoring goals is essential
there is no aim assist here so make sure
you allow time to hone your accuracy
open goal well never mind team play is
perhaps the most important factor though
as three players working together can
run rings around the opponents also you
can place actual rings around your
opponents
so what's the deal with the danger rings
that's all down to which of the variety
of champions you choose as each has
their own attributes and abilities as
with any competitive multiplayer game
making three characters that compliment
one another is very important finding
that balance of offense and defense in
your roster is extra crucial as each
champion has two unique skills that can
massively tip the tide of the game these
operate on a mobile like cool-down
system and can make all the difference
in clutch moments there's huge variety
to including defensive walls disabling
vortices and some sort of combat hug
oh it's called Warsaw now makes much
more sense steel circus wears its
personality firmly on its sleeve
everything from the character designs
emotes victory posies spray tags and
skins all share a cutesy fantastical
feel and if the default options aren't
quite what you're looking for you can
unlock more of all the aforementioned
cosmetics this robot is already pretty
adorable but what if it was dressed as a
cat cats are famously Gouda sports now
we're talking
[Music]
steel circus launches into early access
on Steam on August 8 and is free-to-play
from the start featuring six characters
and two stages however over the coming
months new champions arenas and game
modes will be added meaning that the
solar system's largest sporting event is
just getting started
[Music]